the only thing that can be sure of about
the future is it will be absolutely
fantastic from everybody watching out on
YouTube and listening in on our arthur
c-- clark center for a human imagination
podcast called in to the impossible and
today it's quite a treat to be joined by
three distinguished intellects on my
right is matt kaplan of the planetary
society thank you for joining us happy
to be here and honored to be included in
this group of truly great intellects I'm
not sure I qualified that's like
crossover episode you know cartoons yes
years past and two in front of me is dr.
James Benford who is a proud hometown
hero a alum of UC San Diego graduate in
the class of 1969 and the ph.d program
thank you James for being here
glad to be you're always good to come
back to Paradise yes it's quite lovely
and I should say James is the president
founder of microwave sciences in
Lafayette California and to his right is
Professor Paul Davies a man who needs no
introduction but I'll give him one
anyway he's the founder director of the
Beyond Center at Arizona State
University which in part is sort of an
inspiration for what we wanted the Clark
Center to be a home for intellects and
and excursions and the intellectual
peripatetic landscape that we like to
traverse and I want to thank you so much
for being here and joining us last night
in conversation about ET and we'll talk
a little bit about that with the amongst
the four of us and Paul thank you so
much for being well it's a pleasure to
be here and the Beyond Center we call it
the Center for cool stuff and we
specialize in the impossible yes that's
right so as arthur c clarke our name sec
said the only way to find out what is
possible is to go into the impossible a
little bit or in some cases a lot and
last night we talked about the
possibility or perhaps lack thereof here
on campus in conversation between the
two of you about whether or not 80 is is
perhaps already here not that ET will be
detected but perhaps there are ways to
detect that ET is actually all
among us in in one way or another and I
wondered if we could sort of discuss you
both have novel ideas as to how life
could arise here on our interplanetary
surface that we call home or perhaps
near to us and yet have evaded detection
but you both point to ways that
humankind could make first contact could
discover the origin of another type of
life-form and you both have novel ways
that you've decided to approach this
problem I think maybe I'll start with
with Jim Jim what are some of the more
likely scenarios in your mind that might
pan out successfully to discover the
presence perhaps in the past of an
extraterrestrial civilization I've
proposed recently that we might look
near Earth at the moon or the newly
discovered group of colloidal objects to
see whether or not extraterrestrial
intelligence had in the past including
the distant past located a probe to
observe earth and the residual probes
now inactive might be found or even
active probes today and since then we
would be looking at interstellar
archeology artifacts from the distant
past observing the atmosphere of Earth
hmm would this not be similar to another
creation of our namesake or related to
it in 2001 the monolith that the that is
discovered on the moon and the
concomitant discovery of of gravity by
by primates on earth is that not what
sir arthur c clarke was perhaps
expressing and that's a yes and in the
predecessor a short story called the
sentinel in which the monolith was not
buried it need not be because you
couldn't have seen it from the
telescope's from Earth you have to go
there but burying it made it detectable
only by magnetic field and therefore
you'd have to be very sophisticated and
have orbiters in order to find it it's
very much like that I'm talking about
extraterrestrial artifacts yes
interesting so Paul here as you know we
have the world-famous San Diego Zoo and
whenever I take my kids and they're
reasonably well behaved at least
for them our and as we go there we are
always careful to observe the the
regulation that you may not pound on the
on the cake ages of the Apes or the
primates or whatever that you have to
keep a keep a low profile and and might
it be possible for aliens to escape our
knowledge if they treat us sort of like
those same zoo creatures where they just
don't interact with us but they're here
in some other form is that is that not a
reason that they could be lurking
amongst us or us one of the difficulties
about guessing the motives of an
extraterrestrial civilization is that
they could be stupendously far in
advance of our own and indeed there's no
particular reason why they will be
flesh-and-blood beings the this may it
may well be here on earth that we hand
over the heavy-lifting intellectual
heavy lifting to design systems people
use words like computers and robots but
they fail to capture what in a hundred
years or a thousand years is going to
take place here on earth and that these
will be designed systems and the motives
of the enth generation of design systems
are utterly beyond us and so if we
imagine some other civilization out in
the galaxy perhaps taking an interest in
the service system and interest in
humanity what will they be trying to
achieve will they want to make
themselves known to us or service
without being known or will they ignore
us completely we we don't we have no
idea so my attitude to searching for
signs that we're not alone is to search
wherever we can using whatever
technology we can particularly if it's
cheap and so at the moment SETI has been
dominated by the idea that et will be
beaming messages at earth and we should
sweep the skies with radio telescopes
hoping to stumble across that message
directed to humanity I don't think
that's terribly credible I think we need
to simply search every database because
alien technology may manifest itself in
a way that we would not even think of
and by searching every available
database I mean I'll give you a
a quirky example one of the things
that's being done at the moment it's
free on the internet is sequencing
genomes like crazy so in the Cancer
Research community or the biological
community generally this is the
technology of choices Daisy you'll find
some sort of weird microbe you're
sequencing and all of this stuff is out
there so why don't we just search the
genomes of all of these organisms
viruses bacteria anything else
sukhiya turns on it's all there you can
write algorithms can search through to
see if there's a message from et
considered in them man why might that
happened how might that happened what we
can edit an engineer genomes with our
own technologies that put messages in
genomes craig Venter did just that he
put his email address and some some
poetry of Feynman into the genome of an
engineered organism so you can upload
information into bacteria with viruses
retroviruses is it conceivable but some
advanced civilization has done this
maybe in the deep past and that this
message is somehow preserved we don't
know how it would remain stable over a
long period of time but if they've
solved that problem that the truth might
be inside us not be in here right so
you're you're widely credited with
popularizing an idea that perhaps
because of the exchange between the
planets in particular between Mars and
the earth over a relatively short period
of geological history maybe tens of
millions of years perhaps microbial life
could be exchanged and I think you've
said in the past we might find life on
Mars but it may have come from Earth or
conversely life could come from Mars to
the earth and to my right is of course
not Caplan who's a member of an
organization who spent a lot of time
thinking about Mars and and it's pretty
interesting because you think back to
Percival level in the early part of the
1900s thinking that he saw canals on
Mars and and yet the popularity amongst
the public of exploring Mars for example
still is so enduring and can you speak
about why is Mars so important at least
among in the popular cognizance of a
place to look for life or is it that you
know we're look
for water and and that might be a
harbinger of potential life on Mars what
is it about Mars that's so captivating
why do we keep sending so many very
sophisticated missions to go Tomorrow
People I think it's largely well I mean
the interest goes back to ancient times
but I think Percival Lowell had a lot to
do with this because he really was part
of that move at the turn of the 20th
century and a little before getting
people to think Mars may be very much
like where we live and wouldn't it be
reasonable therefore and of course when
he thought he saw them was Canali and
that the Martians were smart enough to
bring water from the poles to the
equator or was warmer you know that's
when you first started talking about
Metis right the messages we were gonna
build gigantic semaphores and tell the
Martians hey we're over here your
neighbors
I think that's stuck with us I mean just
look at science fiction and a lot of bad
science fiction movies set on Mars that
push this and of course you know NASA's
gone from fall of water because we
followed it we found it we know it's
there quite a bit of it too let's now
really start the serious look for life I
can't
I'm as my boss would say Bill Nye the
Science Guy our CEO that if we found
life on Mars it would change everything
even if we discovered as Paul said that
that life maybe we're cousins right for
me the fundamental question is is life
as we know it just a freak accident that
occurred some in some little corner of
the universe and we are it and maybe
it's spread around a bit maybe to Mars
maybe slightly beyond or is the
transition from non-life to life built
into the fundamental nature of the
universe do we live in an intrinsically
bio-friendly universe in which there's
some sort of life principle or
progressive tendency right at the level
of the laws of physics and chemistry now
if there is such a life principle we
haven't found it yet and if you talk to
physicists and chemists about this
teleology is the technical term that
there's a sort of goal-oriented march of
progress built into nature it's anathema
to them and yet the same people will say
oh the universe is teeming with life on
the assumption that this transition from
non-life to life is a very natural thing
I might say that this has occurred just
during my career in the 1960s I was
really gung-ho for SETI and looking for
aliens and so on and I might as well
have profess an interest in looking for
fairies everybody thought it was absurd
that life was a bizarre freak it was
limited to earth complete waste of time
and money to look for any life beyond
Earth and now everyone says oh yes the
universe is teeming with life
I get the fundamental science really
hasn't changed very much in my career
sort of faith we still don't know how
non-life turns into life a society so
speaking of messaging into space you
know what are they one of the chief
concerns about messaging to space as
expressed by Stephen Hawking who was
Paul Post pointed out in the past came
up with sort of a version of the Fermi
paradox for a famous case of if life is
teeming and abundant throughout the
universe how come where are they you
know that's his question and Hawking had
sort of a corollary not just in space
but in time you know where are all the
time travelers you know there should be
abundant ability for time travelers of
the distant future to transition and
make these quantum leaps backwards in
time and yet we have to date although
there are some people I think are quite
Spacey and quite out of time that I know
personally on the faculty no they're not
they're not my colleagues here but but
nevertheless Stephen Hawking also warned
against the broadcast of our presence
here
perhaps by high-powered microwave
systems such as the kind that you've
pioneered and written about in your
books but do you have concerns about
this messaging Medi messaging
extraterrestrial intelligence in that it
might be you know and eat here kind of
sign for the planet well I'm a moderate
in these matters middle-of-the-road
meaning I think we ought to have a deep
conversation about it through
international means but that had that
opinion which I've held for a long time
has not caught a lot of interest
we're not talking about it widely but I
think if citizen is now possible for a
billionaire to build a beacon that's
visible across hundreds of light-years
we ought to be thinking about whether or
not we won't allow that to happen or and
ask him what kind of message he's going
to send and whether we in fact want to
be heard at all
that's a conversation we need to have
and I would encourage your universities
to advocate such do you feel like we're
on the verge of becoming you know at
least you know junior freshman level
interplanetary species we will actually
send thanks to these benevolent
billionaires I don't know if that if
they are not but but with this
capability as Jim just said to broadcast
but also to fund space missions and as
Elon Musk said he wants to die on Mars
and as Lord Martin Rees told me when he
was here he's worried that Elon will die
on impact on Mars but besides that are
we on the verge of becoming an
interplanetary species ourselves and
perhaps using ourselves as a messenger
to outer space well if you count our
robotic emissaries as being among us as
truly representing us we have been an
inner planet spirit and or planetary
species for decades yeah we certainly
are becoming more so you know are as we
speak Congress is putting its I won't
say best foot forward but a foot forward
into whether and how we're going to get
to Mars and put humans there and whether
that should come before or complement
what we're doing at the moon the the
current administration and therefore
NASA have a somewhat different view that
this part of this Artemis program one
way or another and I'm only talking
about the u.s. of course I think we will
actually be a flesh-and-blood
multiplanetary species at some point if
only Mars maybe Mars in the moon because
really where else would you want to live
except maybe on some huge O'Neill Space
Station right
that's uh that's questionable - but but
I think we're headed in that direction
especially if somebody comes up with a
way to make money out there
right and they're still working on right
and so Paul you gave some arguments as
to why they extraterrestrial
civilization of an intelligent beings
might not want to send themselves or
their emissaries here for one thing you
know the energy requirements needed to
get a massive object here of a
reasonable amount of mass and then to
decelerate that object so that it can
have a nice soft landing and become a
lurking beacon on an inter planter solar
system object as James as professed what
are some of the arguments against as you
presented and as you present an eerie
silence the book which in part our
conversation was base last night what
are some reasons to be pessimistic about
the existence of life elsewhere and
especially technological life not not
just intelligent life well I already
mentioned the big error bars and
surrounds the probability that non life
will turn into life given a habitable
planets there's plenty of real estate on
which life could pop up but what is that
pop up factor that we don't know but
even if it gets going we still of course
don't know how likely it is that simple
microbial life will eventually turn into
complex intelligent life however we do
know the process is called Darwinian
evolution we don't know the process I
turned on life into life so that's still
the the big one did Darwin say something
it was be as foolish to look for the
origin of life as for the origin of
matter he did and it's interesting that
we physicists are now explain the origin
of matter that we we're still stumped
with the origin of life but even
supposing it gets going and you get some
advanced civilization then the question
is how do they best explore their
environment and the idea of traveling
you know flesh-and-blood beings in big
metal objects hurtling through
interstellar space we've been misled by
too much science fiction I'm afraid this
just makes no real sense because why
would you travel you travel only for
exploration or colonization now if you
want to colonize that's a different
matter if you want to explore you you
would send robotic probes as light as
micro miniaturize as possible
highest speeds possible it's still a
very slow process so if we were to send
out probes even to the nearest star a
20% of the speed of light you're still
waiting by 20 years to get that
information back and so it's it's really
a very long-term project my under
undermine the motivation of even the
most curious society but travel for
colonization is a possibility but there
are formidable obstacles so let's just
imagine we might do it you know wouldn't
it be great to send say a thousand
people my Dean we can all think we all
have our favorite lists of who should go
but if we're talking into stellar now
then probably we would never achieve
without some sort of science fiction
technology like warp drives and so on
but were there any physics we know would
never achieve anything that would get
you there in less than several thousand
years and that's okay if you can
hibernate the crew but the one thing
that really bothers me and this has only
emerged in the last ten years or so is
it's not enough to send human beings and
sort of basic foodstuffs potatoes for
example you have to send the entire
microbiology so we've got more cells in
our bodies that are bacteria and archaea
than our own cells so this is part of
the so called microbiome this is the
life-support system of human beings and
every other organism has similar micro
biomes and if you ask the question well
what is the smallest subset of
terrestrial ecology that you can isolate
and be self-sustaining we don't even
know how to go about answering that it's
no good getting halfway there and find
some vital microbes been left behind so
we don't understand enough about the web
of life at that micro level to know just
what it would take so when you get to
the other end you might find a wonderful
planet which is habitable but you're
lacking some really critical stuff you
have us self-sustaining ecosystem of the
other end
another one of your brilliant graduates
Kim Stanley Robinson in his book Aurora
which upset a lot of people he explored
exactly Paul what you're talking about
and the difficulties of getting a colony
ship to any place dealing with the
microbiome and even just dealing with
elements that would be dissipated you
wouldn't be able to you'd have to bring
enough I'm trying to think of what some
of them were some of the compounds that
you would need it disappointed a lot of
us who would you know have always
believed that humans would spread across
the galaxy but it it's a very thoughtful
book yeah well let me say online and in
fact the basis of it was actually wrong
well he he wanted that answer and so he
got you know you can write a story with
any ending you want but they were in
fact they're my brother and I wrote an
extensive critique of that that appears
on that yes science fiction published
that and it it said basically there are
a lot of choices he deliberately made
that made it difficult not because he
didn't discover it being difficult he
wanted you to be impossible he's an
opponent of interstellar flight and I
wanted to meet you there what Paul is
saying he wrote about extensively in a
very nice piece and if people want to
know more about it it appears in a book
that I edited called starship century
and he has an extensive discussion of
those issues about how do you export an
biosphere hmm so I wanna read from the
eerie silence speaking of your brother
yeah this is Paul's book from 2010 so
it's the 10th anniversary of this book
which itself was written on the 50th
anniversary a Frank Drake and the ozma
project the first real search for
extraterrestrial intelligence in West
Virginia with an enormous radio
telescope as I said built in the 60s and
as you say you know it's it's depressing
on one hand how little we've made
despite their truly beyond Moore's law
increase in capability you saw some the
experimental capability we have today
just in UC San Diego and throughout the
whole world Radio Astronomy is because
phenomenally sensitive and yet we
haven't seen it and so the probability
you say here Paul the possibility that
alien civilizations might might look
long ago have created powerful radio
beacons and that humans have the means
to detect them has been studied in
detail by Greg and Jim Benford twin
physicists working in California Greg is
an astrophysicist and also an
award-winning science fiction writer
well Jim is an expert on high intensity
microwave beam technology the way the
Benford see it ancient civilizations
could have many reasons to build a
beacon for example it could be a high
tech moment monument to of pride to what
may be a glorious but now man long
vanished civilization yes beacon is also
a great way to attract attention and
seek and simply make first contact to
anyone detecting it would redouble their
efforts at SETI unless they could
conceivably be an artistic cultural or
religious symbol or even the cosmic
equivalent of graffiti it might be a cry
for help
or as with the humble lighthouse a
warning do you still stand by these
words that were quoted by Paul and in
this book ten years after its
publication yes there are many possible
motivations what I would with what you
left out is it might be a religious
message because a lot of you history is
like the history of Islam is let's
spread our religion and that's what a
lot of people use the airwaves for
already I think that the fact that we
haven't found any beacons is starting to
make that look at less and less probable
and therefore we are approaching a time
when we can say that that's a
proposition which has been falsified but
we haven't looked at much because as you
pointed out you need to stare at a fixed
patch of sky for a long duration because
this thing is going to sweep the plane
of the galaxy and that signal will
repeat and I don't think anybody has
really put in a big systemic effort well
recall though that the breakthrough
listen program is spending 10 million
dollars a year doing exactly that and
they're going to do it for a decade at
the end of that we I'm sure that Yuri
Milner who funded it would like to have
at least a partial answer yes but we're
not there yet I think there were six
years into it yeah of course and that's
frequently said and you brought this up
last night
that you know lack of evidence is not
evidence of absence or absence of
evidence not evidence of absence and yet
it is a you know depressing thing to
think we're 60 years on from Frank Drake
he still thank goodness alive and well
in Northern California his eponymous
Drake Equation being caught of the
forint foundation cornerstone of it as
Paul as you point down the book it's
really an expression of our ignorance
and how little we know about it I always
say if my undergraduates turned in an
equation that had no error bars
associated with it I'd flunk them but
but thinking about looking for nothing
you know basically in all the right
places it's got to do something to the
field and that's why I do you spoke last
night Paul very eloquently about the
possibility of a shadow biosphere can
you say a little bit more about that we
had a conversation on the occasion of
primo Levy's hundredth birthday what
would have been his hundredth birthday a
couple months ago in 2019 on his famous
book the periodic table and also the
which also had its hundred and fiftieth
birthday last year and a lot of things
out there the Dustbuster had its
fortieth anniversary last year are very
important to those of us with kids and I
want to know you know we had a
conversation with a chemist here who
studies this difference in
polymerization and handedness chirality
bio chirality you mentioned something
which you know is very widely
underappreciated I would say can you say
something about this this kind of thing
that could be hiding in plain sight
perhaps in our own bodies or in our
biosphere yes I think this is really
important I've stressed already that the
big unknown factor in the Drake Equation
is the probability that non-life will
turn into life given a suitable planet
we have no idea what that is but if we
now take the optimistic view that most
of my astro by biology colleagues choose
to take which is that life will pop up
all over the place given half a chance
then it means that that transition from
non-life to life is really very likely
under earth-like conditions while no
planet is more earth-like than Earth
itself so shouldn't life have started
many times over right here on our home
planet well how do we know didn't has
anybody trouble to look and the answer
is almost nobody has looked
and we could imagine that life may have
started hundreds of times on earth is it
possible that there more than one form
of life has survived to the present day
now it could be that life as we know it
simply eliminated all the competition
but we know that even among life as we
know it there are for example microbes
called archaea and there we know
microbes called bacteria and they
coexisted peacefully for a very long
period of time so might they be
coexisting with another microbial form
that is not just another branch on the
known tree of life but a separate tree
altogether separate Genesis and how
might we tell mmm and so we've held
meetings at Arizona State University and
the Beyond Center to try and come up
with a strategy where would you look
what would you look for it's actually
pretty hard and I can give you one
example where it would stand out and
this is you mentioned chirality life as
we know it is based on left-handed amino
acids and right-handed sugars that is
that if you look at these molecules in a
mirror
they are certainly allowed by the laws
of physics and chemistry but we don't
find normal life using them but we can
imagine mirror life where life gets
going a second time and everything is
around the other way and these two life
forms wouldn't be in competition really
apart from resources they would be
eating each other because they're being
digestible to each other so we could go
look for a mirror life that's a long
shot obviously all these things are a
long shot but there's a whole lot of
other things we could look for and work
one that is my favorite is that we know
there's an upper limit of temperature in
for life that we know which is about 125
degrees Celsius you find organisms
living at those temperatures in deep
ocean volg and volcanic vents
extremophiles yes we call them
extremophiles I like particularly like
these extreme conditions but the
temperatures coming out of these events
go right up to 300 degrees something
like that no so if we found that there
was nothing living from 125 to 150 and
then we find organisms are living 150 to
180 say then we would zero in on earth
internal biochemistry will be different
been more heat resistant and that would
stand out much harder would be if there
is a should we call it a shadow
biosphere this hypothetical alien life
that will be all among us if it was
intermingled with ordinary life and
liked the same condition so then
separating the sheep from the goats so
to speak would be very hard you can't
tell by looking under a microscope just
little bugs and you need to delve into
the biochemical in it so my girls need
to know what to look for did you have a
comment you want to make sure how much
looking would one have to do in order to
begin to falsify that proposition well a
to falsify it that's a that's a
difficult one is it to say that to say
that there are that we can be absolutely
sure that a hundred percent of
terrestrial microbes our life as we know
it the truth is only a tiny tiny
fraction of terrestrial microbes can be
cultured and only a fraction of those
can be sequenced and so we just
scratched the surface of this microbial
realm we don't know what all those
little bugs are there in there countless
trillions they're all around us and then
we have the viruses as well we have got
the whole virus fear and and we really
are nowhere near but because the
techniques of microbiology are
customized the life that we know it it's
not going to work with anything that
won't cooperate and if you go to a lab
and there's some poor student trying to
get their PhD working with some sort of
extremophiles organism and they have an
organism that doesn't cooperate and
there's floods and tears and you know
how you gotta get your PhD and what
happens to these organisms don't
cooperate well they go down the sink and
they work with something else and that
that's the problem everything is
customized to life you know you go
looking for a you're find a you won't
find B confirmation bias I want to close
with a few more questions for each one
of you so first Matt
what if the falsification comes I mean
what to what extent would that impact
society I almost feel that there's an
urge and urge to feel that we're not
alone and sort of hinted at in Paul's in
Paul's book right the eerie silence that
there's something perplexing paradoxical
it may be unsettling to the human psyche
that what if we are alone what would the
implications be if the hypothesis of
alien life even not technological if we
somehow knew that we're it what would
that mean for Humanity seems like a
pretty big burden for us to carry if we
learn about that because then it says
the universe is ours and what do we
decide to do with it how do we bring the
supposed benefits of whatever our
species is achieved across at least our
piece of the Milky Way I think you're
right I think that we do want to believe
that we're not alone and and yes I
hadn't thought of the significance of
the word eerie and your title Paul but
you're right it would feel strange
nobody wants to be by all by themselves
at least very few of us who was it that
said that if we learn whether we learned
the galaxy is teeming with life or
whether we learn we are by ourselves
either way isn't that the most
significant thing we may ever learn
Thomas it landed in a new world and
found no one there mm-hmm that would
have been very eerie for them because
every land they knew was occupied by
humans right and in fact the new world
was - that's right they watched him
discover it so Jim you've worked on the
you know interface between and with your
brother as well between hard science
physical science science fiction signs
nonfiction
what do you think impels or you know
compels you so vigorously to explore
these really different or are they
different maybe I shouldn't impose my
own viewpoint on things but you know as
a nonfiction writer purely a nonfiction
writer I might spend six months on a
single line or equation or result or
data point and
paper whereas in a work of fiction it's
a farmer Liberty what are the aspects of
these two different genres that appeal
to you are there commonalities and and
lastly can you can you teach someone to
be creative in this way that the human
imagination is so well adapted to but in
such disparate ways the technical the
fictional etc is that's a skill that can
be taught the fundamental thing that's
necessary to be successful in those
realms is one common trait curiosity
you've got to be curious about the world
and and what you're curious about may
not be as important not nearly as
important as the fact that you are
curious and because you're truly curious
you'll keep being curious about more and
more things and that's what makes life
lightly for people like us right
something said you know Einstein said
that curiosity is more important than
knowledge but you know I know I want my
my my heart surgeon to be more
knowledgeable than curious you know what
is this red eating thing in my chest but
it's not easy to make people curious
there are you know people who are not
curious and if a lot of people if we
found that we were alone would just say
let's stay home it's comfortable that's
right to expensive to go out there so
fish when I took the glass of water down
to the blacks Peter and Paul maybe will
close with you
you've written 31 books last time I can
yeah I understand right at the second
you're writing another book which is
really impressive you know as we're
recording this podcast you're on number
32 - you know what what is your process
like I've always been perplexed because
you you are so phenomenally it created
but you over this throughput that spans
and and and goes literally from the
biological to the Astrophysical from the
micro physical to the cosmological is
this is something that you can teach I
mean you're a professor your day job you
know your day to day job as being a
professor can you teach this to young
people and and what do you think of the
future of all these different fields
that you're working and well it's
interesting you should ask about
teaching because the just being
co-teaching with my wife who's
former BBC radio science journalists Co
teaching a course on science
communication and it III when I was a
youngster I had no idea whether I never
thought about writing in fact I barely
scraped through English in high school
and the first piece of science
exposition why I had to do was my PhD
thesis and it was only after that that I
thought well actually I quite like
explaining all this stuff and I could
probably as we would say these days dumb
it down a lot and it started off from
there but I nobody ever taught me how to
do it yeah and what I found it's
interesting that the entire students
were female and among these young women
a couple of them really had what it
takes they were writing sample essays so
it could have been published right away
and some of them were totally hopeless
and so I don't think anything we taught
them apart from a few obvious things you
know try to come to a conclusion and
don't exceed the number of words and so
on I don't think it really helps very
much I think you've either got it or you
haven't and I writes about things I'm
thinking about anyway I'm very fortunate
that the beyond Center has enormous
scope and in my life I regard myself as
really a theoretical physicist that I
know that's the only real research as
far as I'm concerned but I primary
identity astrobiology and cancer
research and philosophy of science and
so on so I'm thinking about these things
anyway so for me to write a book if you
said to me can I write a book on black
holes I could probably do it in a week
but if you give me something more
challenging like I don't know condensed
matter physics or something I know
that's about it would take much longer
and so you know I tend to write but I'm
right about what I'm thinking about it
doesn't take that long you know it's the
actual writing path Naz Blaise Pascal
said if I had more time I could have
made it shorter I do want to ask you
because I don't have these opportunities
very often if there's a
hyper-intelligent species of alien
somewhere or god
something like that what question one
question would you most like to know the
answer to during your lifetime I've
spent a lot of time thinking about
whether the fundamental laws of physics
which is you know this is the sort of
Daily Bread of physicists you there in
the textbooks you use them where where
do they come from could there have been
otherwise Einstein said that the thing
that really interested him was whether a
good law has a choice you know and what
he meant by that you don't have to be
religious but could the world be
otherwise and still have inquiring
beings like ourselves with anything and
that's something I've spent a lot of
time thinking about throughout my career
I sort of got it from Fred Hoyle
actually that he was something even in
the fifties and we don't know the answer
to that question it's very profound
because it transcends actual science
yeah it's about why is the universe
comprehensible and why consumer beings
actually understand it right and could
put that word in other what otherwise
fascinating and very good okay well that
satisfies one of my questions oh that
would be the one question I would ask
what would Paul Davies ask the old one
Matt Kaplan of the Planetary Society
James Benford microwave sciences and
Paul Davies Beyond Center Arizona State
University thank you all so much I want
to encourage everybody online to
subscribe to our YouTube channels and to
our podcast on Apple podcast or stitcher
or wherever you get your podcast please
leave a review and a rating it really
helps us very much to attract and grow
the audience thank you so much Brian
Keating from the campus of UC San Diego
at the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination
the only thing they can be sure of about
the future is it the absolutely
[Music]